[Music]
welcome everybody back to the feed a
world cup infide women's world cup
coverage grand master robert has
alongside me today a familiar face a
friendly face grandmaster daniel
naradiski dania i'm happy to be joined
by you today
i'm nervous i've never done world cup
commentary before and i've never done
commentary with you before no just
kidding it's uh
it's great to be commentating with you
robert i'm super excited lots of things
are going to be decided today so
yeah i can't i can't wait you know
nothing too important just the women's
world cup first place potentially being
decided today if not for gory afghanist
striking back but it's just a casual day
at the office or anything else at stake
or is that is that it um you know
there's also a trip to the finals over
in the world cup but we'll get to that
in a bit first let's remind everybody
who may be new or just for somehow
forgetting the format of this event it's
been a fun ride you've been covering
most of it and well we only have four
players remaining in the world cup two
in the women's world cup plus the third
place
match and
dania 90 minutes for the first 40 moves
30 minutes added after move 40 with the
30 second increment starting from move
one familiar time control to most
indeed and uh time has been a pretty big
factor in in some of these games
yesterday we saw in
in alexander versus alexandra uh we saw
an incredible affair epic battle topsy
turvy and time was playing a role there
was a time scramble there were two time
scrambles and um in fantasy of koryakin
time does not play a role because both
of them have played really really fast
so these matches have different
characteristics they have different
tenors which really is what makes this
tournament so fun to watch you get to
watch so many different types of matches
with their own personalities at the same
time
and as a return we can see the players
on screen here getting ready to start
their games make move one and some very
focused players done in particular
alexander goryachena she needs to win
with those black pieces and we can see
world champion magnus carlson looking a
little calmer he doesn't have as much to
prove today as the games get underway
duda looks right at you danya that's
that's what he's doing right there
he and both of them taking off their
their blazers to reveal white shirts
that was a pretty funny moment
synchronized uh removal of
of outerwear and um magnus generally
likes to be fashionably late but yuri
arrived a minute early so
i don't know what that will pretend and
you mentioned uh sasha griezka and what
she has to do
and you know insofar as there is an art
to winning with the black pieces on
demand
uh you don't want to play e4 a6 you
don't want to do anything insane you
want to let the chance come to you
uh obviously the opening choice is very
important you also don't want to play
the berlin
uh but we will get to that once we take
a look at her game let's begin
with the board of the world champion as
we see e4 on the board
yeah very exciting stuff and well i've
been watching a bunch of olympic
contests last night was table tennis and
synchronized some of that the
synchronized blazer being taken off not
quite involved yet and the irc needs to
take a look at that that seemed like i
would probably give that one an eight it
didn't exactly seem like they were
together on that one they were doing
their own thing but i think we need to
take a look
all right well let's start with magnus
uh let's see how
how quickly they play out all of them
all of their rylo up as theory and which
line they'll choose
and then we'll uh jump around a little
bit because it does seem like there
might be some interesting theoretical
battles here
uh carlson is making motions to play the
the marshall gambit he has not played d6
yet which means that after c3
he is likely to play d5 which remains a
stalwart weapon uh nothing's been proven
in it and here we see the anti-martial
a4
yes because i don't think
uh duda he's looking here to get into
these adventurous waters he'd probably
rather a solid game where he can
maintain a slight edge and if a draw
happens it's a draw they move on to the
tie breaks of course a draw
match being a great result for duda
against carlson uh would you say that
would you'd agree with that donna that
he's trying to avoid the sharpest
theoretical lines and just things where
he could go wrong and give magnus a
victory at the black pieces
absolutely i i honestly don't think he
really minds a draw uh because
you know gouda is a great rapid player
it's it's not like
uh you know he believes his chances in
the rapid i think are are greatly
reduced of course magnus is the favor
but but he's also the favorite in
classical and uh you know i said this
yesterday
drawing the world champion twice there
are worse things that you could be doing
with your time than
than making draws with the world
champion in classical games
that is a very fair statement i would
have to agree with that and well with
the yp 0. a4 he's already attacking this
pawn on b5 and it asks black a
reasonably difficult question because
the main line continues with bishop to
b7 but plenty of people play b4 so it
really depends on your style of how you
want to play here for black because b4
takes away the c3 square so that knight
on b1 looks a little bit silly for the
moment but hands white the c4 square
which can be important and also often
white plays the move a4 to a5 to keep
that b4 pawn away from another pawn
giving white the a4 square potentially
for the bishop to go there and so it's
just an interesting start to this game
where you may wonder why are the players
stopping to think don't they know every
single move inside now there are
different variations that are
approximately equivalent in value you
just want to choose the trajectory of
the game that you think won your
opponent didn't
specifically study for for this
particular day and two just what might
give you the chances that you want and
for magnus he may say let me just make a
draw with black or he said let me keep
some fight left in this game and try to
beat duda with black so danya you're the
prophet
what attitude do you think we're going
to get from magnus today
i i absolutely don't think he really
minds a a tiebreaker
now that doesn't that doesn't
necessarily mean the game will end in a
draw i i just don't think he's going to
do anything to force
to force anything now
how do i know that because the marshall
has a
sometimes it's misperceived uh as a very
aggressive line where you're trying to
win at all costs but in reality
modern theory so well developed the
marshall originally
uh was was formulated by frank marshall
as a weapon to play for a win
uncompromisingly in the rye lopez but as
theory has become more developed four
straws were found and now if you want to
draw with white and your opponent plays
the marshall um as i can shamelessly
report i played a game against ding
liran and in the pro chess league and he
played the marshall and i went into it
and there's a lot of lines where white
basically forces a draw there is some
uncertainty but uh the fact that magnus
didn't mind going for it tells me that
he doesn't mind a draw if that's what
uh if that's where the theory leads and
the fact that duda plays the
anti-martial that's pretty admirable i
think he's
he's not going to to go for an easy
theoretical draw and yeah magnus just
slid the rook over to b8 so he doesn't
play bishop b7 or b4 the two most
popular moves in the line instead of
rook to b which also makes perfect sense
and i wonder dania is d7 to d5 out of
the equation in your future it always
has to be thought about and you have to
under is the e5 pawn that can be
captured that's typical martial play
where you give up that pawn on e5 for
the quick development in a potential
attack but i'm wondering you know you
said you think magnus may just be fine
making a draw if both players are fine
making a drug this game could be over
before our very special guest joins us
in just a few hours so that's what
everybody should be excited for is we
have a guest that you haven't seen on
this show before a very familiar face
someone that you know you respect seen a
lot of his chess games we won't reveal
the name just yet but
hopefully absolutely not
hopefully these two players duking it
out by the time he joins us not a chance
we are not saying the name but it'll be
worth it robert you know it's not like
one of those things your dentist says
you know there's good news and bad news
um
what are the good news oh you're going
to see me you got it six months what are
the bad news oh you got a cavity oh all
right thanks for saying it that way
these are
this is actually a really good guess and
and i'm looking forward to it
uh but good doesn't keep everybody in
suspense it's a great guest you know
and we've had many great guests on the
shows thus far so just uh something to
be excited for
indeed
yeah and
just uh i wanted to throw this in before
i forgot i thought you made a good point
about d5
whether it's out of the equation what i
have played the nt-martial a couple
times and i never know
when d5 is still a threat i just i think
it's really funny i'm always afraid to
make a move like dt like what if my
opponent plays d5 and sacrifices upon i
won't know the theory and i'm gonna get
mated
uh so
so yeah anyways well just felt the need
to throw that in it's important to throw
that in because
i'm not super familiar with the nuances
of these rook b8 lines versus some of
the others but it's clear that magnus
he's avoiding immediate trades he's also
putting that onus back to duda saying
well i'm going rook b8 which is the
third most popular move from the
previous position so now you have to
decide have you studied up on your lines
do you recognize the difference with
playing a bishop b7 right away versus
this rook b8 line is there something
that black has available to him here
that he doesn't had he not played rook
b8 these decisions are really difficult
especially when you're playing the world
champion where there's already some
natural fear when you sit down at the
board but duda of course has beaten
magnus he ended his long unbeaten streak
so maybe he's not as afraid as most
people but still you're playing magnus
carlsen who seems to be in great shape
throughout this world cup
no it's always in the back of your mind
it it really always is and you mentioned
the third most popular move
and i'll take this opportunity to show
how you could have known that how you
could have pretended to be robert hess
for a second i mean
we know everybody wants to be and you
can see uh using the very nifty opening
explorer tool you can see the name of
the opening morphe defense anti-martial
variation
and uh you can see the number of games
reached per position together with the
uh listing of moves and the attended
number of games by popularity nifty
little
uh tool here reaching into rook v8 is
far from the most popular move it finds
100 games
and same goes for white so if you want
to be
uh totally aware of the opening
developments uh and if you want to
combine entertainment with
learning about the opening using
this nifty tool you can see
all of the moves and all of the
popularities and follow along
all right
and i don't feel i don't feel bad at all
uh talking about this in this way
because this is a great tool and it
really does help people follow stuff
this isn't
you know
i'm not trying to sell anybody anything
i promise this is this is genuinely a
good way uh to follow and learn about
the opening well it also is how the pros
do it right when we are getting ready
for games and we're looking through
openings we see okay due to plays this
line he tries to avoid the marshall what
moves can i play that he may not expect
you look down the list oh wait rook b8
that's the third most popular move
probably not something that he's dived
into nearly as much if at all like the
other two and then he has to figure out
those differences at the board which as
we see happening at the moment gives
magnus an early lead on the clock due to
may be facing some uncertainty some
nerves the chance to make the candidates
this event if we're i think being honest
this event is much more important for
duda than it is for magnus carlos megan
just wants to win another chester he's
done everything you can do in chess he's
the world champion he's the highest
rated for so long for duda this is his
first trip to the kin that's on the line
he wants to face off for the world
championship he wants that opportunity
so the nerves have to be all in due this
corner and madden's like just another
day just another chess game i'm gonna
have some fun
yeah it i wonder if he if he actually
thinks that and and he must i mean it
must get easier with time um you win
over and over and over again
although of course uh the effects of any
loss are magnified greatly no pun
intended
um yeah it has begun 11 minutes until
podcast oh boy
it's fine i was just going to say i i
just saw some developments in the magnus
game okay we can we can uh take a quick
look at those well i don't want to even
get to specifics but i look if you look
at the top right of our screen the four
board view it is a martial-like
structure it was a pawn sacrifice by
magnus and because he put the rook on b8
he didn't have to worry about captured
on b5 so he sacrificed a pawn for the
activity
right that's really interesting so it's
it's like a souped-up marshall where
yeah white's got the a file but the a
file doesn't seem particularly relevant
in a position like this and you might
see bishop d6 on queen h4 and you might
see the contours of the main line
marshall i i wonder how
how this will reflect on
uh on the course of the game whether the
eight file will influence how black
handles this position but anyways well
yeah no i was saying one of the
questions who does it benefit to have
those pawns traded sometimes it actually
benefits black because they're your
pawns stuck on the a file that you know
isn't very good for black so anyway that
was just something i wanted to
point out we can take a quick look
before we go on our first break at the
uh developments
further developments in the magnus game
and we do see them following the main
contours of the marshall bishop d6 ricky
when as if nothing had happened on the
queen side queen h4 g3 queen h3
and now i think there's rookie four
and there's probably i'm already
forgetting what the other move is
um
but perhaps i can use yeah there's queen
f3 bishop e3 why does a bunch of moves
in a position like this
yeah and it does look like we're just in
the normal marshall lines and no martial
lines are truly normal blacks down a
pawn there may be a mate on the board
and a few moves or sometimes they just
somehow trade queens that just equal
like i never quite grasp the
ins and outs of the marshall but rookie
4 is a move that's often played as you
said bishop e3 is sort of the tamer
approach just putting your bishop out
developing and trying to defend squares
preemptively and queen f3 that's those
are the queen trade lines that somehow
white tries for but that can be scary
inviting bishop g4 and the light squares
in front of white's king can be in some
real danger so i i'm curious to see how
this one develops
uh
yeah yamcha stuff has has been
so impressive and he's one of those guys
who
it's not that he's not often talked
about i wouldn't say that
but there's a certain sense in which he
flies under the radar a little bit i
don't know if you if i'm making any
sense but
uh you know
uh but but he's incredibly consistent
actually and and he has been for so many
years
uh and he's a very nobody likes to play
him and i mean that in the best possible
way not of course uh because of anything
personality related he's incredibly uh
nice and and he's a consummate
professional but
he's also a professional in the way he
plays he never gives up games easily
and even for his level he's
just wildly consistent well i would say
the quote-unquote issue with somebody
like that is when you're young and
you're crossing 2700 everybody expects
the path will just continue that because
you gained 50 points the year before
then you're going to keep gaining 50
points and oh judah is not you know
nearly 2 800 and that's somehow is a
failure on his part no it's just very
difficult to increase your rating law at
that level and he did get the 27.50 he
did drop back down the 2720s but he's on
his way up i think he's in the best form
of his entire life and he hasn't lost a
single game here in the world cup so
he's just proving that he's here and
he's probably here to stay and in the
quicker time controls he's really
dangerous in the classical time controls
he's also extremely sharp and he just
played the move you called for rook to
e4 and if i'm not mistaken dania g5 is
typically the response here because the
pawn can't be cast out
yeah g5 is the response and that's a
prophylactic move which masquerades
under
the guise of some crazy idea it's
actually not crazy you're stopping rock
h4
um and if bishop takes g5 i believe that
this is bad because there's two
undefended pieces and the queen can drop
back to f5 and attack both of them
and uh they're in the most awkward spots
you can't can't defend both at the same
time
so of course g5 is a pretty serious
weakness of like weakening black's king
side but
but it's far more important
concretely to keep the queen and sponsor
on h3
right and g5 risky move and it's if
magnus doesn't know the ins and outs of
this martial theory
then that could be problematic for the
black king but on flip side that g-pawn
can actually be very useful up there for
some kind of impending attack taking
away the h4 square kicking that rook out
of the center and then trying to take
over the light squares this is a problem
when you have a fianchetto pawn
structure but no bishop in the
fianchetto you want that bishop on b3 to
go right back over to the h1a8 diagonal
but that takes a lot of time whereas
black is looking to bring that bishop
from c8 out to f5 or to g4 and hopefully
into f3 at some point and cause white
some serious damage
indeed shall we say black is trying to
marshal his forces
oh
you know what i proved i i
very much approve of that one because it
was really on point and it wasn't forced
right because i meant to say that anyway
i i i think i'm beginning to learn what
makes a good pun it's i i meant to say
that anywhere i just changed
you know the verb yeah to be martial um
yeah so after g5 you often see uh the
rook or the exchange being sacrificed on
e4
so
for example uh and again i'm
i don't think this is actually what's
going to happen but sometimes you'll see
this situation and white will simply
leave the rook hanging on e4 so don't be
surprised if this happens
and the reason behind the sort of not
knight f3 queen f3
um
something like this occurs and you know
when you give up your light squared
bishop that bishop is crucial for
exploiting as you said the weakness of
these these uh squares that have been
weakened by the move g3 and without the
bishop it's quite a bit harder to
uh exploit the lack of a fiance bishop
on g2 so that's just one of many many
subtleties
which influenced the course of course of
the game but magnus is currently
thinking probably g5 is not the only
move recently
and particularly in this position there
might be other ways to treat this
position but g5 has been played
yeah he goes for g5 he knows the main
tenants this position and for duda who's
down on the clock i i can't quite
determine if i should be concerned for
him because these positions can get
quite sharp and he's down on the clock
or if he was just spending his time to
make sure he could get to this position
and psychology plays a huge role in
chess and just because someone's
spending time does not mean that they're
unfamiliar with the position in fact
sometimes they're kind of goading you
into saying wait a sec if my opponent's
spending time here maybe i should play
the sharpest stuff because they don't
seem to know it and then they're really
just salivating at the opportunity uh
they're just putting their hands
together being like okay here we go
we're going to these really crazy lines
where i can actually show my stuff so i
don't quite know from duda's perspective
which of the two mindsets he currently
has
yeah it is it is hard to say
um and another thing that that is often
not talked about is you know uh well
there's two things first of all these
players have to remember a tremendous
quantity of files and and lines
and uh in an opening as sharp as this uh
you might have prepared something very
similar maybe duda had this position
at home without the a file being open
and he's trying to determine well does
this influence
how i'm so like let's say he remembers
the file with the a file closed he's
trying to compare
and that's a very dangerous thing to do
when you assume that something doesn't
matter uh we've seen a lot of games like
that where where a tiny detail which
doesn't seem important all of a sudden
becomes crucially important uh 15 moves
down some lines so
uh it might be doing a bunch of
different things and we really don't
know right and he could be determining
hey do i want to put my queen on f3 like
daniel was highlighting before do i want
to put queen f1 and offer an early queen
trade which which kind of game am i
looking for here and after queen f1 i
don't think black really wants to trade
queens being down upon but sometimes you
just trade queens to say i have plenty
of compensation because my development
is quicker i already have more minor
pieces out i'll throw my bishop out next
and i should be able to neutralize your
advantage of material with my quick
development
yeah we see uh in the modern treatment
of the marshall something that would be
unthinkable in marshall's day a lot of
players go into an end game like this
and that mimics the shift i was talking
about where originally the marshall was
played as it was it was marketed as the
sharpest lane play the marshall if you
need to win in the rye lopez
um follow in the footsteps of you know
the great attacking player frank james
martin now it's billed as
more of a solid line because everybody
knows the theory everybody knows how to
not get mated so yeah bishop h3 king g1
and and for example rook b8 and
everybody can see the kind of
compensation we're talking about here
this is pretty terrifying even if the
computer always gives some advantage for
white hair as it does here right you
have to maybe play precisely though to
maintain that advantage it's always the
same like jake stakes and bishop e3
maybe this gives a little something
and then knight d2 but i i
didn't like that
i would prefer to have white position
there upper pawn but yes that somehow
this is what the top players do is they
enter an end game down the pawn and just
hold it without any difficulties all of
the other positions are
super unbalanced and super interesting
including magnus's position so let's
quickly check into the world champions
game
and i want to discuss and get your
thoughts on
whether black should in fact take on f1
because that's happened we were
discussing this hypothetically now it's
happened on the board when f1 has been
played
should carlson take and go bishop h3
oh gosh now you're putting me on the
spot trying to predict the moves of a
world champion so one of the key things
here is the queen is defended on h3 so
if i am allowing a queen trade do i want
to initiate it by capturing f1 or do i
want to wait for white to take on h3 so
the reason i bring that up is maybe i
could make a use of like pawn h6 just to
defend that pawn on g5 saying you really
want to trade queens you'll take me my
bishop will land out there but there's a
major difference right if you play h6
and the queen is traded
black's rooks don't get to go to e8 as
well white gets a move in between
whereas in the line that you had
mentioned earlier daniel where he forced
the trade you know by capturing f1 then
playing bishop h3 check you get to
instead of playing h6 maybe your time is
better spent moving your rooks
to e8 so
it's a big question right now i'm sort
of delaying my answer because i'm trying
to think about it while i'm talking not
the easiest feat i might add but i'm
thinking about it here where i don't
really want to trade queens if i'm being
honest i would prefer not to trade
queens but i don't also want to retreat
because where's my queen gonna go to
let's take a queen to h5 that looks like
a very good move trying to get my bishop
into h3 that allows bishop to d1
potentially with tempo and now white's
kicking black's forces back and even
though bishop d1 looks awkward you we
talked about that diagonal right the h1
a8 diagonal my bishop is getting closer
to king side my king feels a lot safer
and whatever bull attack black thought
that he was going to get well toss it
out the window i don't see any attack
yeah bishop d1 is is you see that
actually not so uncommonly in the
marshall and yeah while you're delving
deep into the position thinking about
the nuances and subtleties i'm just
thinking about puns
yeah i was thinking about you know
magnus's name
is made the first part of it is made
it's it's pretty easy to make into a fun
it's often magnified
but i was thinking of whether
any kind of fun material exists with the
last part of his name
but the only thing i can think of is
there's a russian word
which means
means something like heinous
and but then i decided to abandon that
well that describes your puns very well
so i'm glad you just translated that for
me
absolutely so see that's that's what i
occupy my time with so you're saying if
i don't like your puns going forward i
just say your pawns are news
they're they're the moose yeah they're
using like that okay got it
well it's g followed by an n you know
just like his name
yeah so it's perfect now i'm glad you uh
taught me that word
yeah see now now you can really find
your way in
in the moscow metro
by
repeating the word anus
yeah
all right so
but but to your point uh to your
opponent i i agree and i
the way you've explained it
at first i thought ah you know black and
take and go bishop h3 and black is fine
but now i think black is worse
and it's not the kind of you know
it's a pretty concerning worse
and in this position
how exactly does white
uh keep control of the e-file i think a
lot depends on
whether white can maintain an advantage
in this position so what move did you
have in mind here is it an id2
probably
yeah what can happen in this position
let's say black plays f5
you mentioned this earlier it's a
situation where to an untrained eye it
might seem like black is doing amazing
rook is coming to e1 it's mate
but
now you see knight f3
and if black has to go g4 this bishop
gets locked in then knight e5 happens
white sacks the pawn back you might get
a really really nasty end game of course
i'm throwing out a lot of moves here but
um no but your point is very well taken
because
black regains the material that was
sacrificed earlier that marshall gambit
gambit upon you have it back but the
resulting position is just clearly
favorable for white even if black will
have chances to hold the balance so
those positions actually can be even
worse sometimes than those active
counter play down material but all your
pieces are flying in so these are really
difficult decisions and magnus is
already slightly
below dude on the clock he will have to
think hard here trying to figure it out
because another important question donya
is well how many pieces does black want
to trade because you're down a pawn so
do i want two pairs of rooks on the
board just one pair do i want to trade
some of the minor pieces or leave them
all on the board
what if things start going south
what material do i want left that will
maximize my chances of holding the game
and that's actually what you have to
have in the back of your mind not that
you have this pessimistic attitude oh i
might lose this game but you need to
make sure that if all else fails if your
attack doesn't work out that if your
queen is pushed back or the queens are
forced off the board how can i ensure
that i'm not just going to lose this
game i'm down to pawn and right a pawn
is a lot at this level so another idea
that just popped in my head this is
actually a donya type of line what about
rook a8 here
oh what a move that's incredible move
and the idea wow
check
he has taken the queen by the way i i
don't know if it's good but i was just
looking still do it yeah you don't say
about rook e what if i bring my roof to
a8
so he could still do it here right rook
a8 takes bishop h3
right so now i'll probably take the
opportunity to centralize my king
but you're you're embarking on a
completely different
um you know the gps is showing a
different freeway you're going to a1
you're not no longer trying to
infiltrate down the e-file
and i've also removed the guard of your
knight on b1 so watch out for bishop 5.
love it yeah bishop f5 and all of a
sudden
you know white's starting to feel very
uncomfortable about these undeveloped
pieces
ooh
now i'm curious wait what did he do
after queen f1 king f1 because
magnus has gotten up
uh can we make it
can we get a little telescope or
something i'll settle for binoculars but
you
oh look at know
camera work
i still don't know what he did though
i feel like he just didn't make a move
he just took the queen oh he did it yeah
it's
it's magnus's turn am i hallucinate like
oh it is mag okay so that's the magnus
took the queen and got up which is rare
you don't usually get up when you make a
move
uh that it involves a forced response by
your opponent right but
you know
when you gotta go you gotta go and you
made our producers do extra work so
thank you for zooming in like that so we
could see that it was still magnus's
turn because
i was looking at the camera workers i i
all the pieces look like they're on the
same square as the magnets
so it is his turn and he'll need to
figure out what to do he traded queens
and
well now he needs to figure out his
next step here because i love her okay
and i have so many stories like that you
know sometimes even as a as a gm i'll
come back to the board and
i won't be able to tell what my opponent
did and it's so embarrassing you're
holding the pen in your hand
and i'm like what move was played and it
takes like 10 15 seconds i gotta look
over my opponent's scoresheet
um like what kind of a gmr you can't
even tell how the position changed well
and of course i told that story many
times about trying to make me trying to
make two moves in a row well i i have a
great story for you it involves yasser
sarawan and we see that on ticker that
magnus has yet to win the world cup it's
pretty much the only thing he hasn't won
so he's looking to do that of course but
yasser at the world team championship in
ningbo china he was playing against ilya
smirin and
smirn was walking around yasser was
thinking pretty much forever and spirit
comes back to the board and just makes a
move
and
but yasser hadn't moved yet so yasser
like looks at him it's like
ilya i believe the rules of chess
stipulate that i get to make a move
before you make another and it was
hilarious situation very such a yasser
way to phrase it in a very tense moment
during the world team championship final
round uh and it was just so hilarious of
course yasser you know came up with just
a very articulate way of saying hey my
move buddy so graceful
wow that's awesome that's that's that's
hilarious
yeah
ilya
this does remind me that sam geller made
two two moves in our own tilde
and and you know they wheeled the
champagne in
and uh
johann
was there
oh my gosh you know yasser is just an
absolute gem legend
so many good yasser stories that the
answer is the best
yasser is honestly the best and i i can
say that just and and i know everybody
will agree with me
fun times
yeah yeah phrases he has the best way to
phrase things and um
oh man the stories and and
just the places this guy has been it's
one of a kind you mean like mar del
plata
with the glitterage
and then the way he says the names of
the players is like you you want to you
want to be there in 1965 and you're in a
curacao you know you want to be you want
to be there when it's all beats fisher
and and
smith's love and together
it's really like the movie midnight in
paris it's just like what yasser stories
turn into that
you want to be taken back in time and as
you said meet these players in tillberg
or you know in avro 1938 or absolutely
max irva
yeah and um
yeah he's
yeah just amazing so
in any case um
bro
that was even a little bit before
yesterday's time but i'm just you know
adding more adding one to your
list of places in your jokes
oh yeah i have a running joke like
tillberg 1684.
king louis the 16th was vake made the
first move in
in graco's game
oh gosh yeah that yasser knew who the nn
was playing greco in the first game but
you know i i had this stream where i
i was investigating some chess history
books and i was investigating a 16th
century feud between
ray lopez a person
who wrote a book on openings and this is
very little known but there were
there were about seven or eight chess
books that were written in the 1500s
um on oh and they mostly focused on
opening analysis and this guy damiano
who is known for e45 knight f3 f6
and that is one of the great injustices
of the sort of
opening names is that damiano
he didn't advocate for f6 to be played
he was the first person to refute it
and ry lopez who had this feud going
with damiano over whether the italian is
better than i love his i'm serious
uh you literally read passages in their
books you don't think of you know people
in the 1500s engaging in this kind of
trolling uh and that's exactly what they
do rai lopez would say
yeah and you know contrary to what
demiano says
and then in damiano's manuscript um
and i think ry lopez was just jealous
that damiano was first on the scene
anyways
i don't know why i'm going on this
tangent see the mention of yasser's name
just makes me yeah think about chess
history and
all that awesome stuff i i must admit
that is a particularly amazing story of
you know 16th century beef between
players and back in the day they used
pamphlets right they didn't have the
internet to go tweet they were like let
me create a little pamphlet here to talk
about my dissatisfaction with damiano
and in the next break i'll grab the book
or that passages and maybe i'll read it
i'll read a passage from rylo versus
rylo up his book if you know if if the
opportunity presents itself of course
we're watching the world cup i get it
and judah by the way he's got an id2
whoa
and you know you were mentioning this
sacrifice earlier on even after the
queen treats it's not so ridiculous dude
it says it's not ridiculous at all
that's in fact is what i'm aiming for
and dania you know what would be cool if
magus doesn't take
right he's like ah i'll leave that there
my bishop is actually really strong and
i don't need to capture your rook just
yet because that does make white's life
a lot easier
right and the other thing that should be
pointed out the other um
advantage of sacking the exchanges yeah
you get rid of the light squared bishop
so your king becomes entirely safe
without moving
um it it's all because you can ensure
the safety of your king by surrounding
with pieces or by removing potential
attackers and now the light squares are
no longer weak because there's nothing
to exploit them
so that should also be mentioned now
after bishop e7
um i mentioned that white can take on g5
and
i i wasn't necessarily thrilled with
that maybe a move like rook a6
uh is more is more testing or rook a7
something to that effect so white should
not be tied to material here and
uh i think everybody understands by this
point that
in the marshall you can't make your
decision solely on the basis of what
gives you the most material advantage
well actually let me
sort of make or illustrate that point
that you just made where in that line
that you're just looking at with a
bishop e494 you mentioned rook a6 which
is a nice shot so maybe instead of
playing bishop e7 instead of reacting we
should play rook a8 because we can give
up our bishop on d6 as we'll win the
bishop on c1 with a rook a1 after the
trades
that's a great idea rotate again and now
it works for a different reason than
before
if knight d6 you go rook a1
and now white white's worse so i
probably should take on g5 at some point
but i never like i mean i'm always
biased against these positions i just
feel like when a pair of brooks has been
exchanged even if you have three pawns
for the exchange it's
uh it's always very hard to play it's
easy to lose control of the situation if
you're white if you let the rook
infiltrate
right it just seems like black will even
if white may have a little bit advantage
according to the engine you get a couple
pawns it seems like black always has the
play needed to
hold on at the very least and actually
can turn the tables if white's not
careful
that is absolutely
the case and move 20 has been made they
both have spent well no magnus has spent
about half of his time so it doesn't
seem like time will be an issue in this
game but
so many important decisions that both
players have to make in a very short
span
and a good question actually coming in
from the chat so in this line just to
actually go through this one more time
bishop e4
94 bishop e7
the question was asked after bishop e7
rook a6 why not rook a8 now but things
have changed so we always need to take
this into account it seems like rook
takes c6 is not so possible because of
this rook a1 threat but the c6 pawn is
essential to defending that knight on d5
so you can get away with rook takes c6
and after the bishop takes and d5 versus
c1 you have to evaluate this whole mess
now where it's two pawns and a knight
for a rook but also the presence of
opposite colored bishops which could
mean the f7 pawn is in some danger
whereas the bishop one e7 doesn't have
anything to target just yet it's a
really interesting position so it's
worth the question of
should this be explored however rook 8
doesn't just transpose the earlier line
because the c6 pawn can't be captured
i think that's a very good explanation
and and moves changed based on the
position they're played in so uh
um that is
that must be factored in by magnus as he
contemplates whether or not to take this
exchange and we've contemplated whether
or not to take a break and i think we've
decided that we will
and fedex rooting for carlson yes he is
in a weird way it's probably going to
come down to a tie rate um because the
drawing tendency in this position is
very high
although finally you have sat across
from magnus more than pretty much
anybody else in this planet
what does that look tell you about how
magnus is feeling
uh
well i i don't think that he's
super worried
um
so i i guess the question is um
rook c3 rookie 7
i mean it it actually looks pretty good
for white
um i'm wondering what how black would
approach this
you can play rook d1 you can try to
attack the d-pawn but white has rook f7
and rook f4 um
but it's only two pawns so if we trade d
and d pawns it might very likely be a
draw anyway
goodbye
yeah black could try c5 here but i think
rook c4 actually wins
so you can't do that immediately ah
because nigel comes comes around wins
the pawn yeah
over king h8 which would be really sad
that's how the game is going to end
agnes generally misses these things
well he might be trying to calculate
someone like that where father is saying
you know if you can trade off the pawns
and black shouldn't be in too much
danger still has to
uh you know make sure that you don't
blunder anything but white is clearly
with the upper hand at this point
yeah i don't think magnus likes
positions where he's uh he has no
chances to win uh at all and and here
there are no chances to win he's just
defending
um
although i i mean i think that black
is really not going to um to find any
winning chances in this position
uh he could also try f6 and try to save
the pawn
uh but then i get i guess uh rookie
seven
because knight c6 rook c3 seems like a
slightly better version for black than
the other position
uh yeah here kg there there might be
some
knight d7 uh
stuff so
yeah this seems very nasty
right does not look pleasant at all uh
well i sort of foreshadowed this because
i said
bobby you spent a lot of time across the
board from magnets this time it will be
young upon machine but it's time fabi
you've known about this for a while but
the public hasn't i've known about it
and i'm very excited to announce to the
world that you fabiano caruana will be
officially joining the chess.com
broadcast team for the world
championship so you're stuck with me
today you're going to be stuck with me
for a lot longer in november and
december yeah i'm looking forward to it
that's all you have to say you're just
looking forward to it just gonna you
know yeah spending spending a month with
you uh covering the games that'll be fun
there's nothing better than that is
there
uh
you're just a great company oh well look
at you being all nice this is just
because we have company usually if fabio
anna's not here you're just
giving me a lot of slack telling me
horrible puns but it is extremely
exciting that fabiano caruana will be
joining the commentary team for the
world champion to hear his insights
where honestly you have some of the best
out there because you've played magnus
in the championship match which
was just extremely grueling experience
yeah it it's it's uh pretty unique uh
you you don't really know what you're
getting into until you're actually
sitting down there
for the first game uh so yeah it's uh
it's definitely a new experience i mean
no matter how uh
how much how many tournaments the top
players play they it doesn't it doesn't
really compare to to play in a match uh
the unique level of
stress and tension there is and
uh and how difficult it is
for sure and i think the players here
are under a lot of pressure in
particular duda is because he needs to
make his way to the candidates and if he
beats magnus in this game he's there and
if not he will have a second chance
because if magnus ends up winning this
match the third fourth place match will
also determine the second candidate
qualifier whether it's fedocev who's
rooting for magnus or if it will be duda
who of course is rooting for himself in
all matches so
there's a lot still left on the table
here and magnus has won it all
except for this world cup so i wonder
how much does this world cup mean to him
he seems to be taking it very seriously
yeah i think this was uh this is one of
the tournaments that he really wants to
win because it's uh it's the only format
where he's
or he's not won yet um so he probably
considers it
one of the last hurdles uh
and i think that was the reason he
played this because uh i mean
there he doesn't have to qualify for
anything so
uh he's the only player in the world um
besides reject who who had no reason uh
to play this as a qualification
uh so i think that that was his reason
he just wanted to win it uh to have that
um
under his belt as well
do you think part of it might also be
you know during kova there was a lot of
talk of magnus kind of being a slump
and all that jazz
do you think he tries to shut that out
completely or does that serve as kind of
a motivating force um
behind
maybe not his participation in the
tournament but
uh the kind of spirit with which he's
been playing
uh yeah i didn't realize that that he uh
he was considered to be a slump i
thought his results were
were still pretty good uh and all the
most of the online events he was playing
he was um
getting to the final and winning a
number of them so
uh i i guess uh he does have a
you know
the standards for him are very high so
um he's expected to to win many if not
most of events he plays but i still
thought he was doing pretty well
um
but yeah i he hasn't played too many
over the board events and the last one
he played was waikanse and uh
and he didn't
he wasn't really close to winning that
tournament so that was a probably very
big disappointment for him
so maybe he wanted to get some
over-the-board succession
right and this format is
very different than your traditional
round robins or even your swiss events
right because you only get two games of
classical chess in and of course fabiano
your experience here wasn't so pleasant
but i mean what's that dynamic like
where you know that if you played maybe
a 10 game match against a low rate
opponent that would obviously favor you
but in these short spurts kind of how do
you adjust your mentality
yeah i'm not sure on the right person to
ask
[Laughter]
i didn't i didn't do very well um
[Music]
but it's
it is true that um any player no matter
um
no matter the the difference in rating
uh between two opponents uh any match
can
uh
can go in a surprising direction because
uh all it really takes is one mistake
you don't really get second chances too
often
uh and if you do you definitely don't
get through chances
so it's uh yeah a lot of um
a lot of things can happen we saw a lot
of the favorites
uh left pretty quickly um
okay live on of course for
totally different reasons uh
not related to chess at all
um but also ali reza and anish and a lot
of players exited the tournament way
sooner than
than we expected
so there's there's a some some
randomness of course it's not uh there's
not so much randomness because we still
see
uh the final
players are all extremely strong um
and and most of the players in the
storms are very strong but there is that
element of randomness where anyone can
exit at any moment let's see what
decision magnus made
uh
in his game because he was getting
uncomfortably low on time
all right let me refresh to get the
latest position
it's called moves been played the f7
pawn is
no longer for this board and nora is the
c3 pawn
so he's gone for
in this critical position he did decide
against f6 he took the pawn
went back to c2
and king g8 is on the board
which is similar to what we were looking
at right we were looking at rook d1
rather than rook c2 but it doesn't
change
so much right white still is likely to
play like rook to f4 maybe um
or
or also the rook could uh stay on the on
the seventh i was thinking maybe rocks
c7
yeah so the question is uh c5 is that
here d5 and then
yeah d5 rook d1 what's the knight g4 rg4
oh the fork on f6 doesn't look what's
what if i just ignore 93 oh no
oh that's another one
yeah
okay maybe rook d2 was was a a better
way of setting up
um i instead of d1
yeah so it avoids the fork threat after
knight g4
ig4 is still annoying because knight on
f6 could be
you know could start picking up a lot of
pawns but but maybe the h pawn isn't
uh
so crucial maybe black can try push and
96 king f8
three results might be possible here
although yeah of course white probably
has a draw in his pocket
it's a very strange position because
black can sort of try and choose how to
go for you know do i want to trade the c
and d pawns and be
in the situation where i have a knight
and the three pawns the king service the
rook and the one pawn of course the
presence of the rooks helps white's
chances because the rook and the knight
together can attack a piece in a way
that just the night alone won't be able
to but uh five i guess question for you
here is this is a pretty atypical type
of position but
what kind of study do top players do
like in the in the live position like do
you have positions similar to this from
puzzles and positions you've looked at
or your were your instincts just on the
spot here
um i think this this type of position is
just going to be pure calculation um
because it's
there's no there aren't really any
positional considerations here it's just
um
it's just about calculating
move by move stuff um
uh and it does bear some similarities to
some
you know some positions i've i've seen
from some other openings but
um
uh but yeah it's
it's not something you can really study
besides just training your calculation
right i guess i was sort of asking like
do you train positions with
knight rook and three against two rooks
in one sort of a similar end game that
we're seeing here obviously not straight
from the opening but this type of
position
uh i i don't but maybe somebody does
donna do you
oh all the time i do right after the
commentary i
turned to varetsky's
page for 455 and
i just tackle the problems
but yeah i think the decision between
rooka 4x27 is occupying duda's mind
but a case could be made for both i mean
rook for c5 is a pretty devilish draft
for rook g4 but
i would magnify this
that's one of the nice things about rook
f4 is that it stops black's most obvious
idea
and and that's a good thing like if
black is if black doesn't have uh any
useful ideas then white can eventually
start to push the kingside pawns and
create some
potential mating uh mating that on the
king side
uh but black doesn't have any obvious
ideas you can't really attack d4 because
c6 is hanging
and you can't
push c5 so easily
i guess you can play king king g7
it still doesn't threaten uh
still doesn't threaten c5 because you
have the same issue
right so maybe something like h4
and again fc5 then rook g4
yeah
yeah black black would probably um
magnus does not look happy i don't know
if he has a migraine from you know a
long chess tournament or if he's just
really unhappy about his position but he
does not look pleased some migraine from
your commentary
he can't hear that so
you can suffer how do you know that
but he really doesn't look happy at all
yeah i don't know
i guess fabi you know you played the guy
so many times
um when you see a position like this and
you see his
facial reactions do you think that
he's worried about his chances here that
he could lose this game or
do you feel that he has everything under
control
yeah i wouldn't read too much into his
his body language right now he doesn't
seem
unhappy if he's completely lost then he
might um
start to get very despondent but but
here he just looks um
he just looks
kind of concentrated well not anymore
see if what was he up to is like doing
some deep cleaning of that square
centimeter of the cloth
to the human vacuum you know just trying
to sweep away everything that was uh in
front of him
okay let me refresh because i think rook
c7 has been played
it has indeed
and a big moment here for black
so we were looking at c5 immediately or
was it yeah i i realized c5 knight d3 is
possible but then rook d1 um
it might still be possible for black to
do that wait can you throw in
i mean
or yeah cd4 is that is possible actually
oh
that's a very nasty one
then white has to think about
okay then rook d7 but
obviously that's not desirable
um
so d5
what are the other candidate moves
um
[Music]
it's probably only i mean unless white
just wants to make a draw uh and take on
c5 so
if i wants to win this then then d5
should be the move
can you play knight g4 and give up d4 to
get h7
and knight f6 of course take take with
no or you want it to take you know take
right away because your king can't
escape oh that's a very good point
because if your king runs to d8 there's
there's going to be this fork
so you have nothing to lose from this
yeah rook d7 probably and uh
and rook d1 i guess um
the king
rh i don't know he's not pushing this
sheep on probably not enough time but
what if you start
g4
wait a minute
oh no
you know what i'm trying to make work is
something like d3
g5 and
some stalemate idea but i can't quite
find a way to
make it work and there should be a
drawback i'll have to play something
like rook c6 but
um
but no it actually looks very dangerous
well there's rook d2 instead of rook c6
maybe that's the right move
well i just switched back because magnus
has two minutes we're about to see if he
plays c5
not an easy choice
can you
five moves to make
and
um
h5
wow okay um
that does seem pretty loose but
the good news is
d7 is that
an option for what
it looks like a very serious option
and
can you play rook d
one or d2 i don't know which makes
difference at all maybe d5
yeah d5 is interesting
uh
[Music]
yeah this should be fine for black
something's been played
and it
after is maybe no ninety seven
okay it's been played
yeah that went forward
so maybe he'll say
maybe he'll just play rook d one knight
f6 and
um
although black doesn't have to take on
d4 so black might even just ignore that
pawn and and try to go for f2 because
once f2 falls in h2 is also likely to
fall
that's true
this you know the pawn h5 is no less
susceptible to attack but it does take
away the g4 square from the knight so
that's
a pretty
big thing to prevent the defense of the
f2 pawn as you're saying
yeah but this is an important idea if he
doesn't
hop on that train you know knight f6 and
king f7 knight c5 are both very
unpleasant
when rook d1 yep
i can see when i zoomed in
very confident
yeah we might see some sort of a
perpetual very soon there's no
okay why why can play rook d7 and then
force a draw like that i mean knight of
six and rook d7
um
but i'm not sure i feel like like judah
is ambitious and uh
and
he usually doesn't
um
doesn't take the easy way out
so i think that he'll continue playing
this
and there's no real danger that he's
gonna lose this game right sometimes
being overly ambitious you pay the price
and lose games where you shouldn't but
it seems like it's unlosable
well yeah here the thing is uh if he
decides to take on h5
um
then then it is a
position with three results
right and knight f6 king f8 so rook d7
is is the bailout uh
because it sets up the perpetual
and uh
and knight
h5 keeps it very interesting rookie two
and maybe h4 take king h3
uh it's still very likely to draw but
it's it's the fight
yeah i guess black can go after that d4
pawn and that could be problematic if
the c punk is rolling but on the other
side the h g pawns can start rushing up
the board and black needs to be careful
himself
yeah knight f4 uh maybe he should first
kick the king to g4 and then
i guess black could probably take on f4
but who would
who would want but here here's the thing
this is a very very dangerous version
for him
the king is cut off on the last rank and
king
king g5 comes this might just be losing
right
yeah i know there's no
no need for that okay so knight f6 king
of fate has been played and we're about
to see the moment of truth
okay big big choice here okay let's see
go for a night age
to me
you told me not to read body language
but looking at his body language it
seems like he wants to play for a win
here he has that
look to him and the way he's
perched over the board
but
he's maybe he doesn't take any undue
risk
well he's got three minutes to decide
two moves to make until the time control
okay
i wonder if magnus is praying on the
inside of it please don't go knight
takes 85
well he can repeat once auction no he
can't because he's going to e8 never
mind
right so the draw line is specifically
rick d7 knight h7 would be asking for
trouble for olly
it's trumping magnus is too worried
though um his position doesn't
it doesn't seem like he's walking a
tightrope here um
so i i don't think he he's too concerned
if if dude decides to
take on h5 and play on
imagine this kind of bored now if you
ask me
and he's got that all right let's get on
with this already
yeah well just couple moves left until
the time patrol i at the corner of my
eye was peeking at the
oh he takes on h5
he's playing for more
wow
i think magnus is a bit surprised at
that
i don't know maybe i'm over
psychologizing so now there's a choice
for black does he take on d4
is there any case to be made for that
move
um i think that he should i mean he's
probably going to win that d4 point
anyway so
one you want to get rid of the three
pass palms
um
and after rook d4 like you're you're
anyway going to try to play rugby to
work up to next so
um only thing is you might not be able
to achieve it anymore white might play
knight f6 and then
the knight comes back to square to
protect that pawn
yep and he's gone with d2
and h4 is important here to create a
hiding space for the king
that will be the time control move
you could give up both pawns but which
will still probably be a draw like
knight f4
but but then that's not a winning
attempt at all
um if he played like this he's probably
gonna play h4
well magnus's game this happened h4 rook
f2 and king h3
okay
he's thinking
yeah they reached
move it's that's white's 41st move so it
seems like they
are now going to take a bit of time take
a breather because there's stress of
reaching the time patrol
and
to my eyes it still looks like white has
some outside shot of winning this game
but fabiano seems completely unconcerned
and thinks that magnus has this
i'm i'm generally unconcerned because
it's on my game
[Laughter]
but i also i would
that serious amounts of money on this
being a draw eventually
um
it's just so it's so likely because
we're also i think we're going to see a
trade at dnc ponds at some point
and then white has the two pawns and
a symbolic edge i guess white is the
only one who can really play that for a
win but
um but it should be a draw
how many moves this game gonna last up
because dude it doesn't seem like he's
going to make magnus life easy i could
see him playing this out forever
no maybe
it could last a long time
but i actually i'm wondering if black
can play rook h2 king g4 and then rook h
to d2
and in white but yeah now white might
start to go for mating
or not
evil
i don't know maybe knight f4 and then
the king comes to f5 to an f6
or first king f5 i don't know which one
is
yeah this keeps the options open wait a
second there is a meeting that's very
simple rook takes d4 knight f6 and then
king g6 and then or king e6 i'm going to
try to checkmate you at some point very
soon
uh-oh
can white okay black and maybe try rock
g soon
and g4
this is really scary g5 is coming i
don't know
there's a mate
threat if i can't take the pawn
magnus brought his rook back to f7 it
looks like
in the game
so he is worried about the checkmate and
that's why he brings his rook back
telling you there's definitely chances
for
white in this game
it seems not that easy to my eye for
black to just defend everything but i'm
gonna say that magnus is gonna show it's
no problem and that you were right
fabiano i don't say it often i know i
told you i was gonna ignore you when you
joined the broadcast today
you are right
not bad
you can celebrate you know it's okay
this is a great moment
no no celebration just i'm going to make
a very bold prediction i think duda is
going to play rook c8 and not trade
makes myself look good
yeah
i really am going out on a limb here
well he played rook c8 so you got your
wish yeah it's sort of this post 40th
move
lull in the action
and um
yeah these games you know they could go
on forever they could also end
very very quickly i mean it really
really depends and um
i i had a question on a slightly under
well it is related to the topic of long
games but fabi do you think the 30 move
draw
like if that wasn't there
would we have sort of a
epidemic of quick draws in uh did that
happen in past world stops i don't
remember
uh
i don't remember either
i i don't think that
i think you would you would probably
have a few more uh draws
that would uh you know end the 430 moves
um
but if players want to play safe uh then
usually they find a way
and uh
and very often in these formats
you know you see a lot of action no
matter what
um
[Music]
because
players at some point need to
to play for win um
and if they don't want to go for a tie
break then
then they might have no incentive to
to play safe they might go for crazy
complications
um or they might play fighting openings
so i i don't think that we would see a
huge difference but we might see some
difference in terms of
uh you know sometimes players
uh get scared in certain positions
and and if both players are afraid of
losing and very complicated uh you know
but more or less balanced position then
uh then a draw from might uh
you know might end the game because
neither player wants to risk it very
strange question fobby sorry to
interrupt but it's gonna sound weird but
which top player would you say is least
afraid of losing
the least afraid of losing um
i guess
i would
my first question would be what uh
what do you consider top player like
what's what's the rating cut off let's
let's go for like i don't know 2700 plus
but we could also say
27.50 plus so you can choose i don't
care
uh i actually i would put duda up there
um
he would be i don't know
if he would be the
number one pick but he would definitely
be near the top in terms of players who
are
um
[Music]
very fighting players
uh
i don't know if there's players who are
terrified of losing because everyone has
had to deal with a lot of losses to get
to that level
um
but
but for players who
who don't play quite as safe then then
duda is definitely up there
um
i mean probably
alireza i would also put up there
which might also be
because of his age
usually players who are a bit younger
tend to
tend to fight more
so
yeah but it's hard to pick just one
person
it seems like the chat is rooting for
duboff here
as well oh yeah that's that that's a
good uh good pick too yeah
and i guess one you know
the world champion challenger this time
around nepo he seems to play a lot of
fighting chess i don't know if that
means you know he's afraid or not of
losing but his style is definitely
combative so
uh yeah jan is also very very combative
player
so duda you say he is unafraid he is
going toe-to-toe with the world champion
and he's been in these two games at
least every bit his equal obviously
magnus the stronger at high rate of the
two but in these mini match formats
dude has proven that he can withstand
the pressure at least for now so i guess
the result isn't in the books yet but
fabiano if this goes to
a rapid tie break tomorrow what do you
rate dude's chances as
um
i think realistically probably 35
percent
uh i think that that's pretty much fair
because magnus is
uh is really really good in
um
in these formats especially um
in rapid chess he's very very difficult
to beat um
so he's definitely a favorite but
two-game
match maybe 35 is even a bit uh
a bit underestimating uh with his
chances wow
um
i mean it's a two-game match or
potentially two-game match so anything
can happen
um
all in all
that needs to happen is that magnus has
um
you know has one at one hour
where he's now playing at his very best
and
and he could be an underdog um
uh of course he's he should be
should be a pretty big favor but uh
uh but you know in these in this format
i i think anything could happen
don does that surprise you that 35
i mean given the way dude is played in
this tournament i it totally makes sense
i'm i'm thinking of i went on a mental
tangent
uh and probably the answer this is
obvious uh but i'm blanking has magnus
like ever been of course he's not lost a
single time this tournament but has he
even been close to being lost has he had
a single lost position
well he lost to
[Music]
panko
but in i meant more on the classical
portion but yeah that's true he did lose
in the tiebreaker
um the first game
didn't even position against tari at one
point
am i wrong
yeah i know he
there were some fears i think
well in the first game i actually forgot
about us
in the first game with tari he was uh
he wasn't better for most of the game
but he was never really worse or risky
losing
um
[Music]
i don't think he's been in trouble in
the classical from what i remember
yeah and then there was that quick
turnaround atari where
one move is all it takes
magnus
it feels like so long ago it's like a
different era
this tournament has been going on for
weeks and we started
early july
never ending it's like those bold uh
candidates tournaments
two months
bronstein would win a 22 out of 34.
that's what you want favianna right the
these tournaments instead of being you
know 11 rounds and nine rounds 14 right
or 13 rounds like five games say you
want it to be
25 to 35 right yeah that's exactly what
i'm dreaming of i made move location
occasionally zagreb
uh like london
paris you know those candidates
tournaments
i only did that once there was one
tournament um
it was called the grand slam in 2012
where it went from
sao paulo
brazil to uh to bilbao spain
and there was a weak break in between so
it was a very long tournament
with a strange
with a strange break
you just did at the candidates you had a
year-long break between halves
but it was in the same place
that's true unless you're just in a
totally different world and over a year
later isn't that weird that you got a
pack and then you're going to the same
tournament but you're flying like across
the world to continue that tournament i
don't know
yeah it was it was strange
well we get to see faces here and
players that maybe don't take part in
the top level events and magnus had an
interview earlier and i think grishok
said the same that it's easier to play
familiar faces rather than
some of these younger talents or just
lord people do you actually like playing
people that you haven't played before
because we
most regularly see you play against
magnus and against uh you know niche and
lavon and all the top players but do you
enjoy
the
new opponents that you face in the
tournament of this nature or like isle
of man and things like that
if they don't beat me i i do
i mean i was uh excited to play to play
jumabayev because i i'd never played it
before but
i wasn't too excited at the end of it
and now he's you know your mortal enemy
so i never want to speak to him again so
we're not if you're watching
we're we're upset with you here but
on a serious note uh of course you know
results
let's not be result agnostic for a
second and let's just say it's uh you
know any old tournament is it enjoyable
to you know kind of face new people yeah
it is uh
i actually enjoy open tournaments more
so than
uh than the regular close tournaments
with the
players who have played against um
extensively over the last decade
uh so
that's why
isle of man is something i'm looking
forward to uh the grand swiss
um
you gotta yeah you've got a diverse
group of opponents
um you also get a slightly different
um
you know
your players are playing for something a
bit different where
they you know to actually get success
there you have to
to win a lot of games you can't just
win two games and expect that it will
get you near the top you need to win
uh most of your games uh and
and so yeah it's it's a very interesting
um
challenge
all i'm hearing honestly is i like
winning and an event like isle of man
like you tied for first last time you
won many games whereas when you play in
your super tournaments there are a lot
of draws then if you win three games you
win the term so i see what's happening
here i see through
oh gosh well i think they're gonna go
down
oh rook d8 king e5 brook
e8
so knight g6 here would have led to
that draw that we had discussed with
king f6 and takes the knight but due to
continued i mean
this is shades of feresev
he keeps on trying to keep the game
alive and there are some landmines that
magnus has to avoid so first now after
king f6 rook e6
if you go to the fifth rank
um if you go to g5 you get mated rook g4
king f5 g4 king e5 and rookie six is
made that's actually very nice wow i
think if you go to f5
well this is completely unnecessary i
think you should step back but duda
wants to go for this position
and probably play it for another
eight centuries
um
but but it should be a draw
doesn't
like look that obvious when we say
should be a draw we have the eval bar
and everything but you often want that
exact bailout where okay the worst comes
the worst if we were showing earlier in
one of those variations where magnus
could give up his rook for those
remaining two pawns like that was an
easy draw from magnus's perspective so
there's still a bit of life left because
there's no clear-cut solution for magnus
just yet
maybe king d6 is that solution
and try to cling to that c pawn of
course white could repeat but
but uh i guess duda wants rookie 6
king d7 rook g6 and rook g7 is a threat
nothing is entirely
nothing seems to be entirely that
clear-cut everything is a draw but
it's not as clear-cut as magnus would
like it and he's down to eight minutes
so there's a lot of intrigue still
remaining in that game
and
yeah
easy to make a mistake here just put
you're really in the wrong square or not
get your d4 rook back in time in case of
that your rook g6 idea as you were shown
before it could be a problem for magnus
especially as you mentioned because the
clock
and you know if i saw this game without
knowing who the opponents were and i
knew it was dude against carlson
i would say magnus was white
judah is doing what magnus does to other
people i.e like you know it's a draw
um you you keep trying to find it but it
keeps finding ways to prolong the game
to create new problems and it gets
eventually
it gets so irritating that the chances
of a mistake keep on rising even if you
keep defending perfectly so
this has been an incredible showing by
duda even if this game ends in a draw
definitely
putting
massive heat on on the world champion
here there's also not one clear train of
thought as we see magnus hovering over
the board and there he was king d6 where
the king could have gone to f6 and
closer to the past pawns to try to stop
their progress or as was just played
king back to d6 okay they're repeating
moves
okay
just gonna make the draw
i don't know i mean if you're making the
draw then might you might as well play
knight g6 there's absolutely no
i think he's gonna go rookie six
he's thinking so oh he's gonna go rookie
six
john's gonna go rookie six or two six
he's got some good schooling because you
always repeat not don't go to three-time
repetition but repeat gain some time try
to figure it out but you think he's
going rookie six for sure
not for sure i mean of course it's
magnus so you could repeat but
i'm i'm voting rookie six
because the problem now is it's a path
of no return they've already repeated
twice
so if he goes rogue d8 again
you're to get you're going to get
three-time repetition right
and
i feel like he's gone all this way
he sees rookie 656 it's a pretty simple
idea
he wants to go all or nothing he he
wants to win this game and
he's
ready to move but then also
not entirely sure well he's definitely
vacillating i think it's very clear he
he's weighing the options he
he might do either but i think he's just
doing some mental math calculating his
odds in the rapid
right
it really yeah
you could make a case for either
decision being correct
i don't think white's risking after
rookie six but it's easy for me to say
that right yeah you know we don't have
to deal with the consequences
yeah
carlson i said it half jokingly but you
he might be assessing do i have more
chances in this game right now to win or
could things even go wrong with that c
pawn that's still there and do i want to
conserve some energy
some more energy for
tomorrow's tie break if they just make a
draw so there so much to take into
account here that's not just
on the board in front of them
right and i think against almost anybody
else that would go rookie 6 quickly but
it is magnus
and that it's not a bad thing to
you know say well i am playing magnus
because you are
it is true that magnus is probably going
to find all the best moves
so you can just kind of assume that in
most cases
and rookie 6 played
there it is amazing i'm
honestly mad props to duda for
for doing this
he's fighting and fabiano said it dude
is one of the most combative players at
the top level
and
magnus is trying to figure out where to
bring the king king d7
feels natural because you're not
stepping
into any knight force if the rook were
to move from e6 the knight would land
there if it's on c7 or c5 then 96 will
be checked that could be a bit scary but
king d7 has the drawback as you were
pointing out dania of rook g6
threatening rook g7 check to try to
promote that pawn
right yeah both moves have have clear
clear uh flaws to them and that's a
that's a very annoying situation when
you see why both moves could end up
being bad
um and
what always seems to happen is murphy's
law like that
the evil of one of the you play the
movie think is the lesser evil but then
the drawback seems to
manifest itself and you wish you played
the other move
um i'm just gonna take some time here
this is a super important decision
and
it's funny because both players are
deliberating it's a really critical
moment and from magnus i don't know i
still don't get the sense that he knows
100 this is going to be a draw oh yeah
no the eval bar says zeros he's not
thinking in that way he's just trying to
think okay what threats can do to drum
up here what do i have to look out for
and as you were the first to show like
that rook g6 idea doesn't look that
comfortable and
magnus himself he's been putting his
hand on his head quite a bit and
he has not looked happy throughout this
game
nope it just has that ring to it
and you know i think people still
fall into this misconception of course
everybody knows magnus have access to
the evil bar during the game but i think
there's still this idea to echo your
point that
people think oh mac just knows it's a
draw and he's just looking for the way
that he doesn't know it's a draw he does
not know the eval and when you don't
know the evaluation it's very hard to
put yourself in the shoes of somebody
who doesn't know the evaluation when
you're seeing
uh the bar indicate because that gives
you a sense of reassurance
and even if you don't think you have it
you absolutely are operating with a
sense of reassurance like you know find
the right moves to draw this is a
completely added wrinkle even for the
world champion it creates a lot of
pressure for sure it's easy to sit at
home with your engine on looking at the
result of every single move saying yeah
it's fine now this gave white a little
bit of advantage but that's not what
happens when you're in the hot seat
itself you're sitting there
looking at things and you know we talked
about fear earlier in the day not that
the players are really that scared but
they see ideas for themselves the ideas
for their opponent and you want to
neutralize those and sometimes you get
too fixated on a specific idea and you
have to be
sharp to not fall into any trap so rook
g6 was in fact played
rook g7 check
is devastating if we had a free move
rook g7 ends the game so even rook d6
fails to that very same move rook g7
check forcing the rooks off the board
the h pawn becomes a g pawn then g pawn
becomes a queen and that would be that
right
and the last thing i'll say on the topic
is you know i wish that
sometimes people did you know it's easy
to point out the blunders but you know a
lot of the times these players find
crazy only moves and it is that when
it's nobody says anything you know when
magnus finds the top computer move in
some position or the only defensive move
so i would encourage people to
to pay attention to that as well
of course it's entertaining to watch the
computer
we all do that as well but um
you know there's a good reason why these
players are at the top of the game
so
anyways we'll see what happens um let's
check well the magnus game is entering
the time scramble phase
very soon
and duda is contemplating his options
after king e7
and my big question is that the rook
takes c6
is rook d6 is holding everything
together and i think the answer is yes
because the h6 pawn is a little bit too
far away from that knight on f4 you
can't defend like a bishop can so it
looks like black's gonna be able to snag
that one
yeah that's a four struck it's rook c7
rook d7 and you have wait a minute
no no
there's a night there's some night
checks here that are pretty scary
and knight g6 is
scary at first glance
but that's a draw obviously like king f6
i guess
right
and it does look like he took on c6
based on
yeah this game is actually going to end
pretty pretty soon if magnus plays rook
d6 i think
and he will
he a hundred percent will play rookie
yeah he will not pass up the opportunity
to bail to force a draw
and we might even see a repetition rook
c7 or c6
or knight g6
oh and it's wait what is
the king d7 that's that's the drawing
move yeah
yeah yeah king d7
okay we got a refresh again here
this will be a draw
right because knight f8 check does fork
the king of the rook but then rook on c6
is hanging so he'll give up your rook on
h7 for the rook on c6 and duda
he's just looking he's like yeah this is
a draw
he's gonna offer one right here
95.
he has that both of them have that
expression it's about senator john
right so king e6 rook takes and by the
way the goriach in the game against
christina ended in a draw a draw was
agreed to on that board so alexandra
costinia is
your women's world cup champion she
deserves a tremendous amount of praise
she had an amazing event she just went
through without tie breaks just crushing
everybody she is your deserve a champion
that is your chess queen if you will so
incredible absolutely amazing
performance
i think the tiebreaks still go on even
though the players may be like can we
just split the money let's put the
difference right uh anything else at
stake besides prize money there but i
guess they go to tie breaks they'll have
a good time of that and well duda trying
to get his king to help his pawns but
magnus brought his rook to the long side
and this king's gonna come to f7 to step
in front of the pawns you're not making
progress
no we're gonna see i would imagine a
draw for any second
because the work of side checks at the
right moment as you indicated in yeah
you can see the
relaxation
and they're going to tie breaks tomorrow
and boy are those going to be some
competitive tie breaks king g5
and king f7 is important otherwise the
king gets to g6
okay do we really need a new score sheet
for two moves exactly the thought that
is going through their mind like this is
about to be a draw
right
and that reminds me of something i don't
know what to compare that to
like it's just not worth the hassle
it's funny because that was black's 60th
move which fills out the score sheet and
then it's up to duda are you really
going to make magnus play a little more
than have to fill out a new scoresheet
write the names down and all that right
write it down and just say okay it's a
draw we don't need to do any more
writing here
yeah
and
what was thinking yeah i was waiting for
you to make a pun you know the writing's
on the wall but you didn't do it so
wait i don't get it
we just talk about writing and
things like that so
the results are clear the writing's on
the wall it's going to be a draw all
that good stuff no okay oh okay that's
even by whoops
even by my standards that's just who do
you think i think i make those kinds of
fun
you called him andre's brother no panko
or no superman whatever you said no
sepenko yeah that was the worst ever yes
thank
goodness oh gosh
that's terrible
it was but this game
i think that magnus
he doesn't have to sweat it out anymore
he knows the draw
is there a possibility to blunder though
like can
black make some kind of a grease error
and lose this game
white can why we can play king g8 knight
d let's centralize the night oh yeah
and then okay draw all right fine i'll
give you a draw i'll be nice
how sweet of you
yeah
it's funny how even in the way they're
making the moves the game is obviously
over but moves are still being played
i think we just need another camera
angle honestly
right i don't think that's i don't think
we really
can make out who's like playing yeah we
like have one camera towards duda can we
get one towards magnus is that do we
have any say over this i don't think so
that's that's the camera it's a life of
its own um i saw some questions is duda
being disrespectful no because you're
well within your rights to play a
position like this out in fact magnus
has scored many victories over time by
playing positions that should be drawn
with proper play and your opponent makes
a mistake so there's no disrespect here
at all this is of course
due to
just
going for any less
hope that he can win this game but it's
going to be a draw we are going to see
tie breaks tomorrow
which danica be excited for
i am very excited for them and uh
i'm honestly
just you know incredibly impressed with
duda's fighting spirit in this game i
think it really cannot be emphasized
enough how hard it is to
you know gather the
just the courage to constantly you know
keep fighting against magnus and at some
point yeah there was a risk of white
losing you could totally envision some
scenario where and with magnus all of
these are you know emphasized in your
mind so
um it's going to be an exciting one of
course magnus is the favorite but
this has been this match has been played
on completely equal terms dude this
preparation is phenomenal
um i don't think it's going to be a
blowout i think it's going to be a close
one
yeah the live position a few moves have
been made
the king has gone to h5 and there's a
pawn on g4 as well but i think the
simple solution is
as magnus is showing just bring your
rook around
try to get to the h file and
even sacrifice it for the knight on h4
oh like i see another way to lose
i put a g5 knight g4 and then rook h3
mate
well here he's gonna rook h3 and after
knights where he's probably gonna hope
he's gonna rook a5 so i thought he would
be a fight for page three and take the
knight on h4
nancy schmancy
i don't know where magnus keeps he
leaves looking to the side like
expecting someone to do something
there it is draw greed
and
for
young just of duda he makes a second
draw in a row against magnus carlsen
proving to be a tough opponent for him
he actually ended magnus's unbeaten
streak the 125 game unbeaten streak so
duda
is somebody who is you shouldn't take
for granted he is definitely a worthy
competitor and now it heads to rapid
time controls donya
anything can happen in that format
anything can happen and um as fabi very
astutely put it it's
you know duda needs magnus to play badly
for one hour and that's all i can take i
mean we talk about the stakes being high
in the classical portion or in the rapid
portion it's
they're unbelievably high i mean
literally just one second one little
lapse and
you're out so
it's um it's going to be a very fun one
you certainly don't want to miss it it's
going to be vintage world cup action and
the players have great respect for each
other you see them they're talking about
possibilities different lines that could
have happened and tomorrow they have to
gear up for a totally different style of
chess because the rapid time control you
don't have the ability to sit and think
for a half hour on a given move no your
whole game is played with less time than
that so it's going to be a difficult day
for the players not to gather their
nerves make sure that they're feeling
ready for that because the really
intense matchup between two fantastic
players of course magnus carlos and the
longtime world champion the long time
number one rated player in the world
we don't need to say much more than that
but for duda this is a really big
opportunity for him and not just to
defeat magus carlson head to head but
the candidates that's on the line where
if he wins in the rapid tomorrow he
makes his way
to the eight player candidates
tournament who knows what could happen
for him there
yeah the importance of making it to the
candidates also cannot be overstated uh
for these players
uh it is it is the tournament and it is
is the path to the world championship
and that's what's on the mind
of these top games it's not i want to be
competitive
you know it's it's not i want to get the
participation trophy it's you know they
want to become the next world champion
and for very good reason and that
ambition
is what drives these games to be as
competitive
as they are and what makes them so fun
to watch so
it'll be incredible
[Music]
you